how big a role will the wild Hunt play
in the third season of The Witcher why
is Yen wearing that familiar mask and is
that nibbles here are the small details
you missed in the teaser for season
three of The Witcher
the season 3 teaser for The Witcher
begins with an ominous line
it's a heavy statement coming from a
Witcher and especially the eternally
stoic geralt of Rivia though he's a
magically enhanced super-powered Monster
Hunter who's lost at least some of his
humanity geralt is obviously not
entirely emotionless it's just that as a
general rule he likes to play his cards
close to his chest even so fear hasn't
ever really been part of the package
after all scared witchers tend to be
dead witchers so what is the thing that
could frighten a guy who fights gigantic
overpowered Abominations for a living
though the trailer frames geralt's fear
as something that's related to a
particularly Mighty opponent it also
makes clear that Siri and possibly
yennefer are in danger as well he might
have his issues with his former lover
but geralt has a close connection to
both women the fear he admits to may
very well be for their well-being
instead of his own here's hoping it
turns out to be unfounded
apocalypses are often heralded by
foreboding figures in the world of The
Witcher the supposed harbingers of
Calamity take the form of mysterious
writers from an alternate Dimension
these writers are known as the wild Hunt
and audiences were treated to a glimpse
of them at the end of season two in the
final episode geralt Jennifer and Siri
come face to face with the leader of the
wild Hunt in their nightmarish Realm
daughter of Chaos join us
although the trio of Heroes manages to
escape from this plane of existence the
wild Hunt craves the blood of Siri it's
why they chase after her in the trailer
for season three their hunt for her is
because Siri has access to ancient and
long forgotten magic the writers of the
wild Hunt believe her abilities will
save their accursed Dimension from
obliteration powerful and deadly the
wild Hunt will probably be a major Focus
for season 3 of The Witcher especially
considering that some of their history
was expounded on in the prequel series
The Witcher blood origin also known as
the wraiths of morehog the wild Hunt is
led by the elf Eridan all of the wild
Hunt members are elves and they were
created as a means to procure slave
labor from other planes of existence
their purpose gave rise to their status
as heartless reavers hopefully geralt is
up to the task when it comes to
defending Siri and defeating these
long-lived extra planar Raiders
it looks like geralt is out for blood in
The Witcher season 3 but at least he's
taken the time to prepare his gear for
the adventure early in the trailer we
get a nice action shot of The Witcher
pulling out his steel sword eagle-eyed
fans May notice it Now features a line
of runes running down the middle and a
beautiful green glowing Stone fixed to
the guard while these weapon
enhancements don't feature in The
Witcher book series Avid fans of the
video games will quickly recognize the
upgrade system since the first release
runestones have been fixtures of The
Witcher video games however in The
Witcher 3 wild Hunt developers CD
projekt Red took it to the next level
introducing lesser runes runes and
greater runes when equipped runestones
offer different boosts to geralt's
attacks like a chance to burn or cause
bleeding they also change the appearance
of the weapons with colored runes
running down the length of the blades it
looks like The Witcher season 3 will
introduce that upgrade system in some
form to geralt's weapons
as geralt prepares for battle against a
shadowy figure that stands in the hall
in front of him he drinks one of his
many potions to power up The Witcher
only imbibes these deadly concoctions
when he absolutely needs to it's clear
that he's facing a truly dangerous enemy
but who or what is he actually up
against the figure is blurry enough to
keep things delightfully mysterious
however since they wear dark clothes
it's easy to assume that they're either
a member of the wild Hunt or perhaps a
MILF Guardian Soldier however there's
another powerful force that favors black
armor and is at odds with geralt his
fellow witchers after vestemere
discovers that geralt's Ward series
could be the key to restoring witchers
to their former glory he may want to
claim Siri for himself if so geralt
drawing his sword is a pretty clear hint
that the negotiations aren't going very
well another possible identity for the
shadowy figure is none other than the
Mage vilgaforts who has gained more
power within the Brotherhood and may
also be setting his sights on Siri
returns in season 3 with a Vengeance at
the end of season 2 the Assassin is on
the verge of discovering who actually
hired him to pursue Siri he returns in
the teaser in a familiar Halo of fire
but that doesn't mean his appearance is
more of the same the new season could
bring Clarity to some of his biggest
unanswered questions particularly the
mystery of who hired him what do you
want to meet your employer
the obvious identity of Rihanna's
employer may be Emir or even stregabore
but the books reveal him to be someone
else entirely though currently an ally
in the show reince his master in the
novels is none other than vilgaforts the
Mage who helped defend sodden Hill
against nilfgaard vilgafort's has
ulterior motives that are only now
starting to come to the surface
in one of the trailers blink or you'll
miss it moments yennefer can be seen
looking for geralt in a dark torchlit
room when she turns around it's revealed
that she's wearing a mask eagle-eyed
fans will remember the mask from a
previous episode the season 1 episode
bottled appetites sees yennefer set out
to restore her fertility but the most
memorable scene involves her using magic
to conjure up a risque party in a
mansion when geralt and yaskir find her
later on she's sitting amid a sea of
naked bodies watching the erotic events
from behind a lace mask the mask in the
season 3 trailer appears to be the very
same one she wore in that episode it's
unknown at this time as to why Jennifer
puts on a mask and goes running around
dark rooms in season three but the mask
is synonymous with one of season one's
most memorable episodes and teases
another night of unpredictability next
season
The Witcher 3 the wild Hunt can be
described in one word massive the open
world game boasts close to 200 hours of
gameplay in it you play as geralt trying
to find a way to save his surrogate
daughter from the titular wild Hunt with
such an expansive landscape there are
many characters in play so it's no
surprise that Netflix's The Witcher has
only scratched the surface of the
franchise's iconic characters the new
teaser is a window to one character only
briefly featured in the series so far
Philippa eilhart a contemporary of
yennefer's Philippa appears in season 2
mostly to assist spymaster Dykstra but
if the source material is any indication
there's much more in store for the next
appearance of this powerful Sorceress in
the teaser yaskir appears on the wrong
end of a Sharp looking ring that
resembles a Talon philippa's affinity
for transforming into an owl makes her
the likely perpetrator indicating she
will be a player in season 3. like most
sorceresses she is not all that she
appears to be though sometimes
affiliated with dijkstra she always has
an agenda and uses her course as a
political tool to achieve her goals
bring me the bird
it's about time he paid back his
benefactor yaskir has a close connection
to Siri meaning he may be an obstacle
for vicious Philippa to get her hands on
the young Powerhouse the mage's lust for
power is only one of her dastardly
personality traits
The Witcher season 2 saw Siri live and
train in care Morin where she learned
how to become a noble Warrior like the
witchers of the school of the wolf
however that's nothing compared to being
at the center of a continent-wide hunt
that brings up the most formidable
killers in the world the upcoming season
of The Witcher is going to be eventful
for Siri and that's putting it mildly
every Mage Monarch and monster of the
continent is out to capture her and
she'll only be able to hide for so long
before she has to face these demons one
of the storylines will see her become
separated from her Guardians which is
evident in the latest trailer the
continent is a nasty world at the best
of times let alone when the wild Hunt
returns chances are good that she'll
encounter trouble at every corner toward
the end of the trailer we see Jennifer
geralt and Siri wandering around in the
dark completely separated from each
other the threat of danger looms large
and it's clear that something is about
to go down Siri being on her own
indicates that she's going to have to
put her training to good use sooner
rather than later geralt and yennefer
will undoubtedly lend a hand but Siri
will lead to come into her own if she's
going to survive
in the video game The Witcher 3 wild
Hunt players meet an unusual cat who
sits on a table cleaning itself stopping
occasionally to stare at geralt cats are
unique in the universe of The Witcher
they can soak up magic in a way no one
else can except maybe a Witcher cats
hate witchers which is what makes this
cat such an anomaly nicknamed nibbles
his appearance in the season 3 trailer
comes as a welcome surprise given his
origin CD projekt Red cinematic artist
kaitan kapushinski told Kotaku the truth
is nibbles was born as a filmmaking
trick due to a technical necessity that
came up during a crucial meeting in the
video game the game designers decided
they wanted something to distract Gamers
for a short time the decision to add a
cat was a practical and strategic
decision but theories started on the
internet that claimed the cat was a
shape-shifter alas nibbles is just a cat
but he's continued to show up in random
game scenes kapushinski said we never
expected the few appearances it makes in
wild Hunt to be noticed we've put that
cat through a lot of life-threatening
situations and it's been there as a
brave Observer of Gerald's story
unfolding before players now that he's
officially part of the Netflix The
Witcher series we hope he becomes just
as endearing as his video game
counterpart
foreign